I signed off work at the Sunday me as a
reporter and eventually became
investigations editor even pre 9/11 I
was beginning to do stories with an
Islamic slant as a British born aged
myself either certain affinity with
these young guys and when I was
interviewing um I could speak to them in
their own language
[Music]
[Music]
the checkpoint it basically is you know
where Peshawar stops and the tribal
areas begin and there's a sign that
clearly says no foreigners beyond this
point okay
neither of slowly coming home to me
exactly where I am and how dangerous a
place this is and this was a place where
the Taliban and al-qaeda were fleeing
and regrouping
and as we got closer and closer to Kabul
we were being stopped every few miles
eventually they let us through so we've
kind of ushered into the city and that
was able we were in Kabal proper the
first impressions I got was the utter
devastation of the city itself on a
street level looking at these people I -
I you could see the sadness and the
sorrow and the fact that no life isn't
back to normal and isn't about to get
back to normal
[Music]
the next day my plan was to speak to as
many people as possible many ordinary
people as possible by the end of the day
I felt I'd really managed to get to the
heart of what Kabul E's are thinking we
had a pretty early start the next
morning we wanted to get back into
Pakistan before nightfall no shared
manage to find somebody with the right
price and you know who seemed to be
comfortable with him
[Music]
the taxi driver seemed a bit suspicious
I suppose as to what we had been doing
there he was very interested in in me in
particular
the part of me definitely in a physical
sense felt fear and panic we've done all
the hard part as far as I could see you
know we've managed to come in and out of
Afghanistan unscathed is this very all
is gonna go wrong
[Music]
in the end you just have to get get your
passport out and start waving it around
there was a simple as that I pulled up
my British passport and you know like
the Red Sea
everyone kind of parted in front of me
and managed to make my way to the front
of the crowd and ended up on the other
side and finally got into Pakistan as
soon as I got onto the Pakistani side
they checked my passport and and he had
a quick flick through my passport and
noticed that my I didn't have a multiple
visa our hands were shackled with these
old kind of iron fetters all very
medieval looking and quite frightening I
suppose really I was definitely scared
probably remembered actually you know
trembling in fear at the thought of well
what was them
it was very dark and it was difficult to
make out exactly where we were aware we
were going to be kept but I could say I
didn't see that this was a some kind of
enclosed area quite a big gate at the
front
it was like something I've never
experienced before it wasn't happening
to me kind of thing and there was no
overriding smell of hashish with and
practically every inch of space was
taken up that I suppose the feelings of
fear and uncertainty were too powerful
that I was almost in a state of
paralysis for about a good hour or so
where things were happening around me
but I wasn't quite taking him in